[Music]
what up guys is Bart and welcome to
conspiracy one corner and today we're
gonna talk about fake news what is that
actually fake news does anybody know
Antwon take it away or is it all fake
big news um I mean just when you stir up
a story that doesn't really have any
backing to it it's always like hearsay
or it's journalism that at its finest
and its finest what if a story does have
back into it like say the New York Times
says that Bernie Sanders is a Russian
agent and that Putin wants Bernie
Sanders to win within the issue with
that - is that okay technically that is
real news because this is the definition
of news is just like new topics the
definition of news was north east west
and south something that was somehow
boiled in facts somehow it somehow was
it was built in fact but now you only
need like the fact that that information
came out is a fact like the sound
between rumor and knew right exactly did
you hear about the rebuttal what was a
so the New York Times had to retract
that story
did you hear about that now do you know
because I did hear that Bernie Sanders
was accused of being a Russian spy or
working with but I never heard the
retraction same way trucks that Donald
Trump was right they had a whole [ __ ]
report that said no we didn't find that
so the New York Times did that yeah like
what's happening to journalism they did
it to trouble a bunch of times too they
said oh my god we think that Trump Tower
this meeting that Don jr. had with
Russians was like about [ __ ] how to
[ __ ] co-opt our election it wasn't it
was about to do you think about CNN Fox
everything just it just sounds like
garbage to me like I can't believe any a
lot of it just kind of comes from the
digital information age kind of thing
because they're being previously like
there are so many more sources for us to
get news from right like BuzzFeed well
like just from everywhere just all these
other like third party you know vice you
know you want to like whoever you want
to consider is your like news source
writer but there's a lot of other places
that are putting out like news right so
then the problem with all the
traditional news sources and stuff
especially from like a lot of the
writers there it's like how do we get
clicks on our site that's because it
could because we don't have
subscriptions any because of it
forces yeah because they want to go
viral as fast yeah because it's not even
like it's a money thing yeah it's like
and I did it to a certain extent because
they need to pay the bills to stay open
and to pay their writers and so you know
how everything still work but at the
same time that puts you into a weird
kind of like it's kind of like when 24/7
news happen now you need to fill this
all the [ __ ] with you anything [ __ ]
scary thought should we have a BBC where
it's all paid for by the government and
then it's like government now yeah BBC
is government media it is oh I thought
it was big black in some side should see
it some circles circles but also sucks
is whatever went viral first if they
retracted or if they have corrected
information they don't spend the same
amount of energy making because and
because it's not as interesting because
let's you have the clicks they have its
oscillation yeah you know it's like what
are you gonna do like you're not gonna
like promote the like boring next news
thing you're just gonna move on to the
next weekly trial and they sort of
misinformed people yeah just to be fair
they also said that that Trump that
Putin was trying to reelect Trump and
then that came out his fault who then
the same day that they said that Bernie
Bird that boom wanted Bernie to get the
nomination so that's what's being put
out right by the establishments like the
New York Times and a lot of [ __ ] every
party of establishment does fake news
it's just about who's willing to retract
it and say we [ __ ] up right and say it
boldly and proudly instead of just like
maybe they delete the tweet that says
the initial news they should come out
and say we retract we [ __ ] say this
was a liar this was wrong did I had a
policy retraction news you did good job
Bart responsible China's apology video
ever on YouTube I didn't know that you
were attracted it but good for you we
should have got a Streamy for that [ __ ]
yeah they still won't accept the
category of apology video [ __ ]
they need to Business Insider did this
article where there's six corporations
that control ninety percent of media in
America so if there's big six media
giants right that's kind of like a
oligopoly or
monopoly right it's a longer monopolies
one corporation controlling it all all
right but this is several there's yes
that's a large it's an oligarchy because
they all agree on the same information
Anatoly so okay so do you know when the
this was allowed to happen it was in the
nineties during well yeah in 1983 it
says ninety percent of American media
was owned by 50 come exactly but by 2011
that same 90 percent is now controlled
by six and these six companies are
General Electric News Corp disney viacom
time warner and CB happened when Bill
Clinton was in office not that it
wouldn't happen when a Republican was in
office it just happened to happen yeah
Democrat was in office but Democrats are
supposed to be about breaking up
monopolies and stopping media monopolies
and [ __ ]
what happened regardless of who would
have been president thank you that's
what I'm saying when I say that
oftentimes when you vote for somebody
you get through money for the same purse
right well and they also did away with
the rule I think in the 90s or 80s there
was a rule that news had to cover at
least 40% or 30% of the opposing party
it's called the Fairness Doctrine right
but then they lifted that that's why we
can have echo chambers reagan got rid of
it in the 80s yeah and now why did he
get rid of it the Republican argument is
that it's not fair to have a show that
is trying to participate in the free
market that has to kowtow to some
standard that is not what the show wants
to be right I see so so like if JK news
had to have a counterpoint every time
that we said something that would hinder
our creativity on the show right if you
had just which does make sense if you
had to force [ __ ] something like that
into it that's what that's what the
argument is but then the the
counterpoint from a lot of the people
I'm not saying all Democrats agree but
there's a lot of Democrats who think
that the Fairness Doctrine was a good
idea because it allowed time for both
sides whether it was like I have the
Steve green show and the Steve green
show is aired in 300 markets it and my
show is about I think that the corporate
media [ __ ] sucks I'm supposed to have
somebody who's like I have the corporate
media rocks for at least a certain
percentage of my show
making our nose way more interesting
what is it I make pornos way more
interesting for every like seven
heterosexuals you have two homosexuals
in the corner you have people [ __ ]
and then you have people telling you not
to [ __ ] oh
they're standing there in the corner
with the Bible ads or about that's fair
and balanced yeah see yeah but it would
make it more he also controls 70% of our
cable TV ABC Pixar Miramax Marvel
Studios legit but Marvel they're not
what we really have to worry about I
think we have to worry about more the
media side like Time Warner they own CNN
HBO Time Warner Brothers CBS on Showtime
Smithsonian Channel jeopardy 60 minutes
and then Disney owns ABC ESPN Pixar or
whatever so they all have I don't think
they have like they're like network
network on their regular Channel and
then they have like they're the sports
and then they have their live there I
think the owner of News Corp is the only
right representative and then everything
else is basically left-leaning
so then it's not really diverse in
thought in representation so I'm not
even fighting for the right to have more
representation or anything I'm just
saying that the you know there's media
bias because if right right here right
it says 232 media executives control the
information so ok so what's really
interesting about that to me is that
Rupert Murdoch does not disagree about
the war machine Rupert Murdoch's company
Fox name is pushed the Iraq war and
Afghanistan war harder than anybody I've
ever seen but who pushed that as well
ABC CBS yeah NBC and within News Corp in
Congress we have Wall Street Journal New
York Post which are left-leaning
right so there's this idea that there's
a disagreement and all Fox News is
different than these other companies but
they're the [ __ ] same it all kicks up
to news corp yeah yeah and there's a
couple of shows inside of both networks
that maybe disagree with the narrative I
know sometimes not always but sometimes
like a Tucker Carlson will challenge the
war media stuff and then I know that
sometimes not always I've seen Rachel
Maddow
do that as well but they but they always
seem to
like as a network agree on the talking
point then it goes worldwide - because
it says here News Corp owns the top
three newspapers and three continents
Wall Street Journal in the u.s. the Sun
in Europe and the Australian in
Australia so pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah
well I mean no one reads the newspaper
anymore I think it's probably like blogs
and [ __ ] like that radio they own radio
so back in the 90s 1995 the FCC they
forbade the companies to own over 40 per
stations but Clear Channel owns 1,200
stations so there you go right so is
there is there true fairness on Clear
Channel like probably not no it seems
like all of our media is controlled by
this group of the big six
so in movies the big six box office
sales hit seven billion in 2010 that's
more than the next hundred and forty
studios they only made 3.5 billion
combined so the big six
they made double what the hundred and
forty studios made so there's a lot of
money in media right I wish they were
owned by one of them maybe we get paid
more - you also wouldn't be gonna put
someone that looks like Bart right there
what's crazy is that all these mergers
they're saying here that they're just
combining forces like crazy and kind of
getting closer to a monopoly cuz they're
all included right they're already a
monopoly I think cuz you know why
because every time you turn on any of
these networks it's all talking about
the same thing
usually right now coronavirus and how
it's gonna [ __ ] over all of us even
though it's so limited it's so small
it's something that maybe you should
take this a precaution and wash your
hands a lot everyone set right but but
is it something that's gonna [ __ ]
kill you I mean 23 million people died
of the flu when did dr. Mike said he
says I didn't watch this vid he alert
but not anxious something like that
something like that like don't [ __ ]
freak out oh yeah be healthy what's that
John Oliver did a really good piece on
coronavirus where he's like you you can
worry but you don't have to like scream
and panic but also don't take it so
chill just find that nice balance sure
of like being alert that's chill about
Quran and see that even
that is a challenge to what the media is
saying about it because if you turn on
every [ __ ] channel it's at Corona
Vanek Dania
holy [ __ ] did you know that three people
died in America or whatever it's and
it's working because Costco is getting
emptied out every day in [ __ ]
people die of car accidents every day
yeah so but nobody is like oh my god I
can't get my car you know what it is to
me like like the compares between car
and airplane where people are like oh
man I'm talking about being on two
airplanes like your quality i exactly
drive to the airport they be on everyone
same with the crown device like you're
more likely to die of the flu than our
little virus but then you have this
whole stigma of this other thing that it
doesn't even apply exactly that's the
way the news is taking these details and
spinning it to cause this panic if it
bleeds it leads
Danny flicks I saw a guide on his
motorcycle today pretty much we cam when
I passed by there's no way that guy's a
lot there was a red stripe on the road
jeez and it was gnarly as [ __ ] and the
cops did that swivel thing where you
stop you have to stop and sit there
forever
yeah and then when I was like a [ __ ] in
a storm up and then when I actually
passed by I was like oh yeah I do think
though in the States we have a really
irresponsible media and how it divides
the the citizens the people here only
because by traveling you don't feel the
tension within the citizens and the
racial tension and the class tension and
all that stuff but in the States
I feel like they're ready to like set
off and and I think it's the media's
fault not being responsible for you know
their their cliques and their greed and
whatever it goes in and it kind of hurts
the the I don't want to say nationalism
but it's like the idea of togetherness
like yeah they do the divide and conquer
really well out here in the States
better than anyone
yep
[Music]